yay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah all right
we're doing it live this seems
inappropriate
I don't think classes for this yeah I
have to now I'm going to tweet out that
I am live oh my Instagram Jen oh no oh
my youtube channel everything okay hi hi
hi hi everyone this deer yay this is so
exciting
breasts this shy person they see deer
right yeah do you right it's bricks I am
on a roof I'm on a roof that of the
house that made me a knight on if you
guys have not been following our social
media we live here now and oh I'm saying
I'm sorry to make you know
we're in um hi everyone happy 3rd of
July are you sick
I was sick I mean everyone's a little
bit sick in their own brain but I was
sick and now I'm better
my voice is actually the shrunken
suspended days
where's goose goose is in boardings you
thought the doggy daycare that loves her
so hard and that she loved so hard
Oh someone says they're hungover
congratulations
the lights just went on in your house
yeah I just went on you can come over
you can come but did you see the lights
just when I know we both have the
reaction to the lights being on also you
can be in this frame so you can see that
I really really thought out my summer
wardrobe I'm wearing a friend try
bathing suit top that meant a lot to me
when I was bordering it hung over at
VidCon I also ate a Red Lobster today
things have been good oh yeah we ate at
Red Lobster today I'm wearing a french
fry bathing suit top and we're sitting
on a roof so really like kings we are
living like kings right now king crab
legs oh yeah that too yeah
house tour well the house is getting
worked out so not much of a house tour
to be decided on just yet but because we
have bit the lights just went back on
again we'll figure it out but because we
have been you know with friends all
weekend and celebrating the 4th of July
which is tomorrow but like days in
advance I just want to do a livestream
with you guys
because I have obviously as you know me
not shot in any shot not shot in any
videos I don't film I haven't properly
filmed any videos to post today or last
Friday or last Wednesday or this
Wednesday so I thought it would be nice
to just talk to you guys and see how you
guys are hanging out on the 3rd of July
everyone keeps asking where as beans and
goose have met because mamrie and I have
this house together absolutely not
No 0% 0% beans is a very particular
beast he goose is a very particular
beast they are wonderful in isolation
awful together I met each I've met each
beans and goose individually goose is
less judgmental but more temperamental
yeah these judges beans judges quietly
goose judges with her jaw yeah you know
you stand with goose at least beans you
like she's talking behind my back I know
it as soon as I leave the room
beans us talking about me but I want her
to like me know exactly any of you that
have an Ashley that you went to high
school with that's beans literally
baloney because guess what beans isn't
that cute
but for some reason isn't that cute Oh
beans isn't that cute but for some
reason everyone agrees beans is cute but
like everyone individually it's like I
don't see it what the world is like it's
the mud it's the most real thing I've
ever seen
I disagree okay
I like means there's something the beans
give me yeah you can come sitting oh you
got hot on beans now you're out beans us
the nicest life of all of us so I
thought we would do a fun livestream I'm
sort of July and do some Q&A kind of
stuff just hanging out because I want to
incorporate live streams on this channel
we regularly more weekly I talked about
this before when I was at VidCon so I
wouldn't think no come back come back
you back are we on a roof
yes no this is just our go grace
bought up a Rugrats house growing up
watching Rugrats I never I never I grew
up in Iowa I didn't know these were
really you doing your standup oh this
isn't my standup this is a freaking
Rugrats house it's beautiful
congratulations
thank you grace and mamrie did their and
beans and the beans is this Tim this is
not Tim this is not my brother Tim very
very much Oh where'd I get this french
fry top I got it when I was very
hungover at VidCon on Etsy because I
thought I was so hungover that I
deserved a treat and so I went on Etsy
and I ordered myself this french fried
top which is important okay
french fry emoji is perfect who is he
who is you we're friends
who is you Iowa for the win someone said
yeah Chris and I are friends we hang out
we got a Red Lobster we drink beers we
sit on roofs we celebrate the 3rd of
July thoughts on twenty one pilots you
like music so much more than I like
music that you have a specific case of
music you like twenty one pilots I think
that one day they're bad you're gonna
never ruin this whole I think that
twenty one pilots has it it has its
place they have their place yeah I am
NOT gonna disagree with them they have
their place okay is you Larry someone
that my name is not Larry no where is
goose goose is in a safe space where
she's not murdering it who's first under
blanket under top Jim I think Chris dog
clothing so that she feels comfortable
because their anxiety gets the best of
it all right
I mean can we all not relate to that
yeah it's just tight fitting clothes
when you get scared yeah I feels like
gentle hugs constantly a constant hug a
concert hug who doesn't want to feel
comfort oh sorry guys you're fine you're
fine sorry
you guys all got sleepy oh my god oh my
god everything's fine this house is
perfect you booked thoughts under
fireworks
we're actually waiting and seeing if
there are gonna be fireworks around but
I don't think there will be okay we're
the old person town it's true okay
woman's last time you went without a
shower you guys the last video I posted
I had long hair I was short hair because
chlorine plus extensions that should not
be in your hair longer than I had them
in my hair was Bad News Bears so they
all came out of my hair last night this
is not the way I thought this weekend
would go but a happy fourth of July
anyway if you guys have questions let us
know I'm trying to read these comments
so they're going so fast that I can't
Wendy Judi is yeah I know when did you
do is was supposed to do my hair last
week but I had to shoot something and I
had to recut to her for next week which
doesn't matter anyway because all the
extensions fell up well we have a nice
story about grace Helbig so graceless
suppose grace is gonna take me to WWE
Raw with my friend she was gonna me and
my friend and grace and mamrie we're
gonna go to W be raw grace couldn't go
cuz she had she's works I was shooting
with Jack Perry you guys have Jack I'm
so sorry guys so sleepy why so sleepy
she's actually an actual job I don't she
gave me all three tickets and I took my
friends and we had a great time at
Monday Night Raw with grace helbig's
tickets and grace Helbig seats so this
is very nice of her and I think that the
content manager of WV Raw was a little
disappointed when we showed up and we
said we're grace Helbig you know you
know what are you doing why do you why
do you type in a way down there are you
want instant messenger no I'm trying to
log into our Wi-Fi so I can know your
can we tell your moms lol thing is that
funny have you talked about that I think
I talk about it a lot you love the story
producer so I recently told Burks that
my mom when I like we're just talking
like this is our third friend oh that my
mom used to text my brother Tim you guys
know him Tim and I and every time she
texted us she signed off lol mom because
she thought a well meant lots of love
and not law like the thing about no loud
yeah so she used to text me grace your
grandfather kind of remembers my name
again llama yeah think about it like I
swear we're not doing that that's
literally the environment shifting you
guys that's the Earth on its axis yeah
no it's funny to think about like
Grandma slipped LOL mom it's funny to me
I'm sorry
Oh mom Loma and then Tim and I would
text each other okay wait I'm just going
online what I called your your the your
french fries it's something else Marie
does which I don't know if that is
correct
they're not it's their french fries okay
go ahead go answer some questions I
can't read I have bad eyesight
I don't know what's happening on the
screen it's also my first live stream
I've ever been a part of and really ya
know I'm not an Internet person grace
tell me what memes were a few weeks ago
bricks had no idea that scumbag Steve
connect Steve is the funniest thing I've
ever and Brook said no sorry guys sorry
sorry sorry sorry I swear to god I'm not
doing this on purpose I swear to god I'm
just lifting computers yeah I swear to
[ __ ] god but looks like Steve is
hilarious if you don't know about
scumbag Steve or nice guy Larry what's
his name good day Greg Greg
not a nice guy Larry good guy Greg
scumbag Steve
vengeance dad PTSD kid yeah these are
the funniest things I've ever seen
and I did not know what they were and we
were on a plane ride Minneapolis back to
LA and we were laughing uncontrollably
to the point of the woman on the plane
after we we got on the plane like 8:00
a.m. or laughing like maniacs and then
we landed in Los Angeles two hours later
and she was like you guys are laughing a
lot knows like you ordered wine at 9:00
a.m. on a flight I watched it happen
yeah so maybe highway was wrong I was a
little bit of engine snow but it had a
little bit of engine back let's go back
Steve is the funniest thing I've ever
seen and I will memes are better than
any comedy that's ever existed on the
planet Pete with memes big-time big
giant bags every time okay I just
tweeted out for gonna come hang out with
us so we'll see if everyone comes and
hangs out it's okay to drink Coronas on
live streams right I'm lighting up oh
yeah it's swear to God I swear to god
I'm sorry I'm trying to light this with
the screen of my laptop right now
because the Sun is setting and it's
getting very dark yet true that's this
is all true hold on I got it
watch this Oh fix it fix it fix it I
know how to the internet works hold on
I'm trying
how top uh that looks terrible in this
expired yeah now it looks like we're in
are you afraid of the dark
that's 20 years past anyone who's
watching this is I know that I meant
they swing sets are not scary until very
dark out and they're right swinging by
themselves if you ever see a swing set
swinging by itself call the police
that's terrifying
cuz guess what dead baby in it well okay
ghost baby I don't mean dead baby that's
ghost babies scarier yeah you ain't that
okay
someone's up there alt how did how did
you guys meet
where is good everyone keeps asking for
gooses goose is in her dog boarding
facility she is safe and happy and
having a wonderful time
Brooks when he came back to used to be
someone's head I would said the other
day grace was there yeah Brooks to the
stamp she won't usually be in Franklin
it was very very fun it was a delight uh
how are you at the drag race finale
barely recovering
barely I told Burks I was like oh I
missed it you missed it next season you
have to start watching with me yeah it's
so good and also when they do the
finales they don't obviously let
everyone in the audience know who the
winner is for two weeks like you can't
trust that 200 people are gonna just
walk around and not accidentally like
spoil it so they shoot multiple endings
so you have I didn't know who the winner
was until it actually aired and then I
didn't even watch the airing I got
spoiled on social media there I found
out that Sasha one which it made me very
very happy cuz that's my brother wanted
to win what work team Abu and no we just
started watching The Bachelorette you
only if you guys watch The Bachelor at
this season cuz it is insane we just
started I love wobbu wobbu moon don't be
a fake fan I'm a big baboon family don't
be a fake one boom what's his name Greg
are like I like Wicky
wah boom there's some sincerity behind
that yeah then what they love Rachel
they love Rachel everyone loves Rachel
all we want is for Rachel to be happy
that's the gist of the entire bachelor
season not me I won't well boom define
well he's the next Bachelor he's going
it's going Mikey can go jump off a cliff
okay cuz that guy just stirred it up
whole time but Jesse you guys know we we
deep dived into after the episode where
they like told each other off in the
most embarrassing way possible yeah okay
I'm Blakey okay
yeah well you don't know junk because
you don't bend it so sad but I still
love la boum so much and it turns out
that they are deep enemies from years
ago
No from a previous reality show that
they were on a reality show in which
while boom tried to consciously uncouple
his ice God what exile it's caught ex
Isle it was on the logo channel or like
we one of those own being one of those
but then he tried to consciously
uncouple his ex and then they brought
Blake and Blake apparently slept with
Babu's ex it was his like roommate yeah
so Blake is not good also this is months
ago that this air we are not current or
up-to-date on and we watch a lot of
someone's that nice hat dude oh thanks
mamrie it's actually maybe it's got a
fish on it she forgot it when she left
she left yeah no we're slowly leaving
important things behind are you sick in
the brain of course physically getting
better all good
Oh someone's gonna [ __ ] me in the [ __ ]
with a rake mom whoa no and also that's
dangerous how would that feel good no
that person it got acknowledgment cuz
they wanted attention oh we gave it to
him yeah yeah we give in to the to the
trolls if somebody trolls you ignore
them
where's maybe went oh maybe Sabine's
look at her Instagram she's with the
beans the beans is a hard so beans loved
being here hated everyone else being
here well either of us adopt you know
it's a lot of paperwork no I'm out
I'm out cat yeah why have you was in
Katya don't know Denver someone just a
Denver all cats you were in Denver yeah
I've been there so of you yeah I can't
read any of this I know how is this good
I is okay I was in boarding because um
she couldn't come down because we had a
lot of dogs and people here this weekend
there's a lot of dodges well I just hear
um and I didn't know when we were
leaving so I couldn't bring her down
unfortunately dad shirt for the win yeah
New Zealand in New Zealand boot okay
ever been to Memphis have you ever been
to Memphis I have I drink I drink at
this bar called the UM it was a really
cool Memphis bar I don't remember what
it's called but it was cool I've been to
Memphis I perform there this with the
Ducks go the Ducks gonna walk I stayed
in the duck hotel what if you there's
this fancy hotel where ducks walk and
then they're like and then the ducks go
in an elevator and they go on the roof
and everybody watches the Ducks and
there they film it with their phones and
they're like can you believe this and
I'm like yeah they're ducks but I still
filmed it and I got excited too so I've
been to Memphis I've stated a duck hotel
story checks out I guess yeah Memphis is
great great at the Peabody
it's called the Peabody you're right
it's called the Peabody oh is that what
it's called yeah other cuz that's what
we're into brunch today did we let's
call the Peabody I'm I've been yesterday
we made breakfast today we went to love
you to breakfast yesterday
oh all the days of fun together took so
so hard if you guys have followed any of
us on social media you guys know great
to do a show it used to be um I agree I
agree with I agree with whoever said
that I think grace should do more live
shows but I find grace to be very funny
thanks um no
[Laughter]
intimidates me to know it so in
Australia whoo
Australia where are you from an
Australia Courtney Barnett is my
favorite current musician someone just
said I'll show y'all cats
yeah but corny brunettes number one
she's from Melbourne I want to go to
Melbourne you guys booked grace on a
Melbourne tour come with and hang out
and then me and Courtney bright that
will become good yeah this sure it's
great I'm taking over your Q&A no I'm
trying to read everyone keeps telling me
the audition for us now don't whose face
is squishier in Simon Says Louisiana
okay and some of that's probably science
oh I did a podcast got probably saying
oh yeah probably Saints have also done
shows in Louisiana Lafayette and New
Orleans
oh I sound like mamrie their memory
turns it up when she wants to sound
southern well maybe it's a little bit
drunk she gets super separate
southerners hit I know that's I like
Leslie I'm like go on this is the only
time anyone's allowed to say y'all
without me complaining at all whatsoever
my mom says y'all but you're from well
my mom's from Central Missouri someone
says [ __ ] this sushi is so good well god
bless good luck congratulations where
did you get it
ordered from and how are you watching
the live stream while you'll eat sushi I
mean obviously it's not that good
because you took some time to type all
caps [ __ ] the sushi you're so good yes I
mean sushi ah bless your heart team 1000
team ten is your voice okay my voice is
kind a lot better I am slowly slowly
coming back to life my mom is very
concerned and so I'm yeah everything is
working out I'm learning to talk in my
belly and not in my
that's what I have to learn how to do
Alaska I've been to Alaska twice unless
you love us glasses
Alaska's number three favorite state
what's the first two persons California
right - is Hawaii in Alaska uh no Iowa
Iowa's top bottom ten least favorite
state Iowa rooks we need a new album
I've tried to pull one out okay yeah
that's what grace is that used to be
shows it was the new album I'm putting
that's very nice but that's the goal
that's why I did the UCB show for the
new album it's good Oh Gracie's new
album I need I mean I like Chumbawamba
let me have that album please Ohio
someone just screamed Colorado I see
y'all been to all these places I want to
go and have a car someone said okay to
you someone says flamin young I read
someone wants you I can't see old people
just look Florida Malaysia it goes to
quick access Canada favorite pie what's
your favorite pie
I guess peach cobbler
is that a pie key lime grace talk I see
that goes to I don't de verano San
Antonio bar town I've never been too far
tap well it's been most nights in far
town I'm a giraffe doesn't true
[Laughter]
I like you guys are just shouting out
location again I'm gonna end this it
like
it's 24 minutes and I'm gonna end it
about 30 minutes and you guys any
questions feel free to send away or do
you just want to shout out locations
yeah well we'll read them out loud we'll
just be like yeah that's a place
Michigan I seen it yeah
Trevor surroundings rehab someone just
screams me I've been talked to about it
ever see Alice Portugal New York
locations
I'll pack new house tour eventually
mamrie and I are still moving in it's a
little slow and steady process and we
will show you guys when the deflated
there's one bad this we got one there's
what not me I don't live here there's
one bad inflating wait so the watermelon
inflating can we flip it is that is that
acceptable yeah okay hold on we'll see
if they've bad inflate oh oh no no oh
man grace I'm ruining your whole you're
a whole brand okay here we go
hold on bad inflate II oh it doesn't
read look how dead it is I said that is
just like a dead watermelon who knows
there's a dead watermelon it's it's
sorry guys we're distracted by the fact
that we can I quit
somebody so my Jim Jim you're here now
but I just learned that we can filter
all of this what what okay
let's try this and see if this works no
no no no we're back okay it looks fine I
good okay
well no I want to see the cop no oh
shoot guys I ruined everything
I'll let that go away
well I wrote urban Red Lobster if you're
in Palm Springs oh yeah we had a great
third of July what do we do today we
went to Red Lobster uh-huh
we tried to go to the mirror house
closed forever yeah the guy told us that
his wife owns the car at the same car
that you own and that that mirror house
is closed forever we couldn't go take
for this this head time um what else we
swam in the pool yeah we ate cheese's I
just made chicken welcome to your
parents just talking right now yeah
different I'm trying to read these
comments with chats you do it thank you
see that's fine that looks better it's
cuter for sure memory came outside we
were I was running this hedge goes this
has been through it this weekend yeah we
didn't used to look like that you know
it used to be straight brim
somehow it's like this now this is her
hat she was like big little liars I
haven't watched it I started watching
the first episode of it and it looked
amazing but I was distracted and I was
like I can't be because this show looks
too good
nice hat thank you hmm I can't well
where the heck was that comment when I
was wearing it I mean you can't read
can't see it I don't know what's
happening I have bad vision I'm trying
to get his I'm trying to get the filters
out of the way but Riverdale everyone's
is ruined everything Saturday everybody
sing Saturday live question mark yeah I
did it this audition for it yeah that's
the thing happy didn't get it North
Carolina and Riverdale Brooks I'm not
too deep oh yeah you should come on the
podcast maybe that was the phone that
was blue neither one of us did that on
purpose okay
have you seen River don't know guys I
haven't seen what's River there it's a
show sounds like a place sounds like a
sounds like a mythical place that like
Frodo stopped at to like get
refreshments from elves Rivendell that's
what I'm thinking about
do you know what I'm talking about yes
okay all right Rivendell yeah yeah
that's where Elrond lives and that's
where they combine the Fellowship of the
Ring I just got excited
someone says Perth Australia
cats Perth Australia rules man no Perth
is weird
no it's Perth you're weird but no I love
Perth I'm a huge John Butler Trio fan
Perth is very cool it's like the the
most isolated city on the planet where
to go Perth if you live in Perth you a
weirdo and I like it have you ever done
a show I've never been to Australia
I am I sold it not emotionally just
actually physically
Austin Norway San Jose I love Brazil
national with dates and places we've
been to them all what state have you
been to grace let's play this game what
state how have you not been to Montana
ooh we're gonna go to my yeah well I
mean the plan is to go to Glacier
National Park this summer yeah we're
gonna try clothes a foot way but I've
been to Montana to delight what's the
state you haven't been to that you want
to go to I don't I honestly think I've
been off 50 really yeah
well bag it yes I just tore and don't
make any money that's how your stand-up
comedian you tour you see everywhere and
it all kinda go to Yellowstone I haven't
been I've been yelled I know I've never
been we're gonna glacier well Grayson go
to Yellowstone but well figured out just
like that you guys are time you said
we'd know where we don't have the brain
capacity no we're just drinking and
eating chicken don't worry we're just
sitting on a roof drinking eating
chicken just no more youtubers actually
it's been a half hour so I'm gonna head
out guys I want to do more live streams
with you guys I'm trying to get on a
schedule or maybe every Friday we do
live streams let me know on any social
media if that's something you guys are
gonna do because this is fun and I like
talking you guys like this next time I
tried not to be on a roof and I'll try
to have a more charismatic co-host what
the dude I was trying to let you take
over if I live streamed it'd be like me
and my mom and she'd just be like call
me an email
okay have a wonderful wonderful safe
night guys enjoy the 4th of July
well tell you guys um at some point in
the future yeah if you if you're in a
state where fireworks aren't legal you
just duct tape a bunch